gestern die schocknachricht zu den fc
bayern münchen trainer julian nagelsmann
hat corona und das trotz vollständigen
impfschutz er befindet sich derzeit in
quarantäne da doppelt geimpft ist darf
man aber auf einen milden verlauf hoffen
ja die eigentliche nachricht mit
sprengstoff dahinter ist aber folgendes
könnten sich weitere spieler bei ihr
angesteckt haben denn die bild erfahren
hat sind fünf spieler des fc bayern
nicht geimpft und die wollen sich auch
zukünftig nicht impfen lassen das ist
ziemlich unverständlich für den boss der
deutschen fußball liga christian seifert
aber an
meiner sicht ein klares jahr darüber
hinaus
übt man da ja auch einen beruf aus oder
auch schon ziemlich gut bezahlten beruf
wo es halt nicht möglich ist
körperlich abstand zu halten sondern im
gegenteil man lebt sozusagen von der
körperlichen lehrt
insofern auf der einen seite jahr kann
jeder für sich entscheiden auf der
anderen seite hat man aber auch eine
professionelle verantwortung sich und
seinem körper gegenüber und man verdient
hat mit seinem körper geld und sogar
ziemlich viel insofern habe ich wenig
verständnis dafür wenn man sich nicht
impfen lässt das will ich ganz klar
sagen ja und net hat ausgerechnet
fußballer die mit die ersten waren die
ja nach denen die groner regeln wieder
gelockert wurden überhaupt den betrieb
wieder aufnehmen durften und dann muss
man ja auch noch im hinterkopf haben
dass beispielsweise die zuschauer in
vielen stadien nur hinein dürfen wenn
sie geimpft sind das ist ein thema über
das man diskutieren und vielleicht auch
streiten kann und das machen weil der
staat nur um sport und alex schönburg
also bitte das duell
[Musik]
es ist sehr ungewöhnlich dass wir
miteinander streiten da wäre eigentlich
den meisten dingen immer einig sind aber
außer der liebe zum fc bayern natürlich
ja ok aber
im wesentlichen dingen des lebens sind
bei uns sehen wir uns einig aber gestern
festgestellt dass dubai das dass du bei
dem beim thema impfpflicht für
profifußballer vollkommen anderer
meinung ist mir das mal da liegen ja ich
finde auch wenn es keine gesetzliche
pflicht für fußballer gibt wie für
andere menschen natürlich auch nicht
gibt es doch eine verpflichtung finde
ich gerade für professionelle fußballer
sich impfen zu lassen erstens sich
selbst gegenüber ihrem körper den
mitspielern gegenüber das ist finde ich
ein völliges team eine team unfähigkeit
eines fußballers den eigenen kollegen
über sich nicht impfen zu lassen weil
dem jedem kontakt sport kommt man den
anderen er und der besteht halt immer
ein risiko und zweitens beziehungsweise
drittens schon dem eigenen verein
gegenüber dem arbeitgeber und der ganzen
liga weil am ende kann es sogar sein sie
im eishockey zum beispiel das ganze
spiele abgesagt werden
wenn corona in einer mannschaft
ausbricht und als ungeimpfter ist das
risiko natürlich extrem groß ich halte
das um es einmal ziemlich deutlich zu
sagen für total unsolidarisch und
hirnloses verhalten als bundesligaprofi
sie nicht zu impfen und ich finde wenn
man sieben oder sogar beim fc bayern
auch zum teil achtstellige gehälter
kassiert kann man auch mal eben den
ärmel hochkrempeln sagte man trägt
jugend also ich bin ja vollkommen
anderer meinung ich trage kein alter hut
ich bin auch doppelt geimpft ich würde
auch sofort die dritte impfung impfung
gehe weil ich ein grundvertrauen schon
schon immer in die pharmaindustrie habe
ich hab' ich nehme auch erst noch in
tabletten ohne sie vorher ins labor zu
geben und zu gehen was da drin sind ich
habe mich immer impfen lassen ich es
auch ein frühstücksei ohne zu wissen wo
das herkommt ich finde ohne einen
gewissen vertrauen und ohne einen
gewissen glauben an dass die dinge
funktionieren könnte ich nicht in meinen
gebäude getreten weil ich an die statik
des gebäudes spiele haben wir jetzt ich
will dir sagen ich kann ich kann ich bin
kein kämpft gegner aber ich finde es
unverantwortlich menschen
durch die durch eine art moralische
pflicht
einzureden sich impfen zu lassen man
muss das noch mal klar sagen ich bin
geimpft und ich würde auch die dritte
impfung aber schon bei meinem sohn der
18 jahre alt ist vollkommen gesund
sportlich sich normal ernährt der nicht
der auch nicht in einer weise jeden tag
eine u-bahn ist sondern zu hause ist und
dort nintendo spielt und dann und dann
in den park hinaus geht mit seinen
freunden denn der sagt er will sich er
soll sich erwählt sich impfen lassen
damit er auf eine party gehen kann finde
ich das unverantwortlich und genau so
finde ich es unverantwortlich für ein
wenn ein oder nachvollziehbar wenn ein
junger
23-jähriger top-anwärter
lewandowski der ist so gesund wir hatten
immunsystem wie hall polen wie soll der
die wenn der eine persönliche
entscheidung trifft und sagt ich möchte
nicht eine spritze im arm haben von
einem in der in der in einer von einem
jahr ein medikament oder von der info
die in eile entwickelt worden ist die
wobei deren zulassung
prozedur ein paar abkürzungen genommen
worden ist und sagt ich nehme dieses
risiko in kauf aber ich finde anderen
leuten einzureden dass sie dieses dass
dieses risiko in kauf nehmen sollen das
ist eine abwägung als junger als junger
mann mit einem intakten immunsystem
ist die gefahr an corona zu erkranken
und einen schweren verlauf zu sagen wie
gering der im gegensatz ist aber der
eingriff in den körper von einer 1 1
eine eines eines eines impfstoffes dass
in den
genen system manipuliert ist ein riesen
eingriffen ich nehme das in kauf ich
habe sein vertrauen aber ich habe hohen
respekt vor form von menschen die das
nicht haben und gerade wenn deren
immunsystem intakt ist und ich aber
wieder zu wort
also erstens muss leider sagen voller
stolz erster ja die fußballer sind
durchtrainiert und mag das risiko
geringer sein wir haben einen aktuellen
fall über den wir auch berichten wir in
den nächsten tagen rune jarstein der
torwart von hertha bsc norwegische
nationalspieler hatte im frühjahr corona
bevor die impfsaison begonnen hatte und
er leidet immer noch hat eine
herzmuskelentzündung und es war lange
unsicher ob er überhaupt jemals wieder
fußball spielen kann ist jetzt leicht
wieder im training bei hertha bsc das
ist der gesunde spieler von dem du
gerade gesprochen hast wo nix passieren
kann außer ein bisschen schnupfen erster
zweiter kaum eine berufsgruppe nimmt so
viel medizin fortschritte für sich in
anspruch wie professionelle fußballer
den werden spritzen eingejagt ohne ende
gegen schmerzen gegen hiergegen da sie
haben in jedem fall immer die beste
medizinische betreuung und nur bei einem
impfstoff von dem sie angeblich wissen
was drin ist zogen sie zusammen und
sagen nein drittens wenn sie im
verweigerer sind in der bundesliga dann
frage ich mich warum haben sie nicht den
arsch in der hose und zu sagen jawohl
wir machen es aus dem und dem grund
nicht nein auch die spieler des fc
bayern die namen sind nicht bekannt wir
recherchieren natürlich auch daran da
kamen schon die ersten anwalts drohungen
wenn ihr das und das macht dann wir
können das nicht bestätigen ob der ein
oder andere spieler ist deswegen bleiben
wir mal bei anonymität das ist denn auch
nicht nur hirnlose oder auch noch feige
aber ich kann dir sagen warum sie das
nicht öffentlich machen warum sie mich
in der bild zeitung lesen wollen wer
sich nicht geimpfter weil es inzwischen
einen extremen moralischen druck denn
finde ich bin ich sehr sehr
problematisch ich verstehe sagt zwänge
aber ich diese moralische keule lehne
ich ab ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
möchte auch nicht in einem land leben wo
die gesellschaft oder der staat mit dem
anspruch der herkommen nicht ständig zu
erziehen bekommt das eben auch in der
klimadebatte ehrlich gesagt die ganze
zeit ist rage ich werde stehe wir
gewöhnen uns langsam daran dass wir das
wir dass wir keine kinder sind und dass
uns das dass uns der test uns der start
in diese erziehungsberechtigte
moralische moralische
ratschläge geben weil der moralische
druck impfen zu lassen verein für mich
hochproblematisch verstehe sachzwänge
aber es dürfen nicht menschen gezwungen
werden eine eine impfung zu machen das
sagt auch ist der
verfassungsrechtler papier sagt das ganz
eindeutig es ist hoch hoch problematisch
sie können keinen impfzwang machen das
ist unmenschlich ist es für den spieler
sprachen die menschenwürde ist also ich
glaube wir kommen auf keinen grünen
zweig in der tat ist es nicht der staat
sondern ist es der verstand der ihnen
sagen müsste dass sie sich impfen lassen
sollen aber gut ich akzeptiere so wie du
bist die war graf auch wenn du manchmal
pumpen redest
dann geben
[Musik]